My family left Korea
when I was seven years old,
and I never really took the time
to learn its history
and culture until a few years ago.
You probably know of Korea
as two different countries
as North and South Korea,
but relative to its overall history,
which begins as early as 700 BC,
this is a fairly recent occurrence
and actually for much of its history
it's been attacked and controlled
by foreign forces
and has had to constantly fight for
independence. And today
I'm going to be sharing
a project that I did in my 4th
year of architecture school
that's taught me a bit
about the painful history of Korea,
An has made me think a little deeper
about the meaning of a shared identity,
as well as the role of architecture
in addressing complex
cultural and political conflicts.
In 1910, Korea was invaded
and colonized by Japan
until 1945 when Japan
was defeated by the Allied forces
in the Second World War,
Korea was liberated
from Japanese rule, but the US
and the Soviet Union
both wanted a piece
of Korea, so they decided
that the country will be split in half.
the Soviets occupying the North
and the Americans occupying the South.
They simply drew a line across the map
and decided to divide the country
along the 38th Parallel,
which has now become the DMZ.
Of course, the Koreans didn't
get a say in any of this.
the Soviets helped elect a communist
guerrilla leader into office
and the Americans helped a US
educated Democratic leader into office.
Since then, both the North and South
desperately wanted a united Korea,
but of course under their own
rule and political regime,
and there was a lot of tension
between the two sides.
In 1953, the North Korean leader
tried to overthrow the South
Korean government in an attempt
to unify the two countries,
which led to the Korean War
pitting Koreans against Koreans.
Since then, the two countries have been
in a perpetual state of war,
forcing young Korean men in their 20s
into mandatory military
service for 18 months,
leaving a pretty big gap
in its economy and social structure.
If you are a fan of Korean dramas,
this also sometimes serves
as a convenient resolution to the plot.
So while the two countries
still use the same language,
they've diverged on
pretty much all aspects,
including political ideology,
culture and economy.
For most South Koreans, reunification
is an unrealistic, impractical,
and even a contentious idea.
The vast majority of the South
Korean population today,
especially the younger generation,
oppose reunification
just until the late 90s.
There was around 80%
support from South Koreans
for reunification,
but a poll in 2011 showed that
the number had been reduced to 56%.
People in my grandparents generation,
however, still have long lost
family members on the
other side of the border.
This is the footage
from a rare reunion in 2018
that was granted by the North
Korean government.
The families were
reunited after 70 years
and were given 11 hours together
over the time span of three days
to see each other,
with no repeat visits allowed.
The families were selected
based on a lottery and there are 56,000
Koreans on the waiting list
to be picked for visits like this.
Every year, around
3000 of these people die,
reducing the number of families
waiting to be reunited.
This event was the result of a government
led process towards reunification,
which was started in 2000,
in the June 15th
North - South joint Declaration
where both governments agree
to promote reunification
in their respective countries.
I also remember pretty clearly
as a kid in elementary school
learning about our friendly neighbors
in the North
and learning songs about reunification.
Practical and economic concerns
aside, in instances
when the two Koreans meet,
it's been shown over and over again
that it's an unexplainable
emotional experience.
Well, the reunification still remains
a very lofty goal,
something on the very far horizon
for both nations.
One of the efforts to strengthen
the North - South relations
was the push to create
industrial and economic ties
by establishing areas like
the Kaesong Industrial Park
which would allow
South Korean companies to employ
cheap labor in North Korea
while creating jobs and income
for the North Korean economy.
Two years after its opening,
the number of North Korean
staff hit 10,000 workers
a year after it doubled, and in 2012,
it reached over 50,000.
The accumulated earnings
from goods produced at the complex rose
from some 100,000,000 US dollars in 2007
to 2 billion dollars in 2013.
The park is located
10 kilometers North of the DMZ
an it's the only direct
road and rail access
between North and South Korea.
The DMZ, the Korean Demilitarized Zone,
is an incredibly unique
condition of its own.
It's been a four kilometer
buffer between North and South Korea
since the Korean War in 1953.
And this restricted land
hasn't been altered by human hands
for the past 70 years,
and as a result, has created
a natural paradise
for an incredibly diverse range of animal
and plant species that have
pretty much vanished
in many other parts of the world.
However, the barbed wire
fence that runs along
the DMZ is impenetrable
not only for people but also for animals,
and this has created a fragmented
landscape between the two
mega ecosystems,
limiting the possibility
of further growth.
When connected,
The ecosystem has huge
environmental possibilities
and as a whole,
could become the starting point
for a natural wildlife corridor
extending to the rest of Asia.
In 2014, during my 4th year studio,
we were given a project brief
which was to create a border crossing
between any two countries.
I decided on the border
between North and South Korea,
not just for personal reasons,
but for the complex social,
economic and environmental conditions.
Based on my research,
I wanted to create a commercial border
crossing on the existing road
to the industrial region,
but at the same time wanted
to address the separation of
the wildlife corridor
by the barbed wire fence.
The separation of the wildlife
corridor by the road
connecting the industrial regions
by also introducing an Animal Crossing.
This Animal Crossing
would be structurally supported
by public observation towers
on either sides of the border.
As the two buildings hold up and connect
the broken wildlife corridors
in four directions,
it would, first of all, provide
a public attraction that would
allow us to admire the wildlife,
let us witness the economic activity
that's happening and at the same time,
provide a place where we can gaze over
to the other side of the border,
where, in the least,
it could be the beginning of some kind of
kindred emotions.
This actually isn't my typical process
for designing a building,
but on this project
there was a descriptive word
that kept coming to my mind
as I mulled over the conditions.
In Korean,
you would call this gin-jang,
loosely translating into
tension.
Tension, Miriam Webster describes
as: a state of latent hostility
or opposition between
individuals or groups.
It's also described as:
Inner striving, unrest
or imbalance, often with physiological
indication of emotion.
It's also the act
or action of stretching, or the condition
or degree of being
stretched to stiffness.
And finally it's
either of two balancing forces
causing or tending to cause extension.
Of course,
the bridge would be in most parts
self supporting,
with a substantial structure,
but I felt like the symbolic gesture
of the two buildings
holding up the bridge, even in some minor way,
added a powerful narrative
that I didn't really want to compromise.
And the motion of pulling and tension
in large part, drove the design
of the individual buildings
as I went through multiple iterations.
The two buildings are identical
and they torque as it goes up,
which means that each floor plate
rotates at an angle, providing
unique views on each floor,
like views to the mountains,
views of the city on the other side of the border,
views to the building across the border,
views to the Animal Crossing,
and we also have views
for the border control.
Maybe the possibility of a united
Korea is long gone.
Maybe the two countries have drifted
way too far apart,
that reunification is
an unrealistic proposition.
But our history is always a part of us,
and if nothing else,
maybe it could at least provide a place
where people can experience
the beautiful surroundings
and reflect on our collective memory
and ponder on what it means to
have a shared identity.